buonasera a tutti
avevo 10 anni quando la prima volta mi
hanno chiamato terrona pensate una
bambina e pensate come si può sentire
quando si sente chiamare così cos'è un
[ __ ] non lo so
la difficoltà più grande è una volta a
12 anni quando a un certo punto mi sono
ritrovata a letto
come faccio a spiegare dove la
basilicata tutti dovrebbero sapere cos'è
la pasticca ta eppure nessuno
comprendeva e mi diceva continuano a
dire ma perché esiste sì esiste dovresti
saperlo che esiste la basilicata non
devo essere al dirti dove potenza
l'adolescenza è stata difficilissima
davvero tanto perché incontravo i miei
amici che arrivavano da milano roma
firenze bologna e mi parlavano di mondi
paralleli
fast food cose che era abituato a vedere
nelle serie tv nei film dei film
americani
io mi sentivo persa mi sentivo isolata
non sapevo che cosa fare
e sapete non è facile per una ragazzina
di 14 16 anni ritrovarsi a non avere
stimoli
probabilmente ho sbagliato allora quando
era ancora adolescente a 18 anni ha
lasciato la mia basilicata ho deciso di
andare via ho preso altre strade sono ho
girato il mondo scoperto e ho dato
diciamo un nuovo modo di vedere la vita
ho conosciuto nuove culture
però fondamentalmente il problema è che
ho capito un certo punto che
non ero soddisfatta
per l'amor del cielo io sono contenta
quando si va via dalla propria terra
perché serve per imparare serve per
apprendere serve per conoscere molto
ancora più contenta sono quando quello
che hai conosciuto è quello che ho
imparato lo riporti nella tua terra e
quindi la terrona che era in me
scalpitava e diceva che cosa devo fare
perché io continuo ad essere un numero
perché io continuo a fare qualcosa
quando realmente io potrei fare qualcosa
per la mia terra quando realmente potrà
incontrare persone che come me sono
rientrate sono tornate nella mia
basilicata e nella mia città e vogliono
scoprire il mondo
e così piano piano mi sono accorta che
quello che era abituata a vedere e c'è
una regione il mezzogiorno quello che
stiamo vivendo adesso era solo
un'apparenza
vedevo quello che eravamo abituati a
vedere come una città un luogo una casa
solo per quello che era e invece
dovevamo guardare oltre dovevamo cercare
di fare in modo che
di ricreare ecco di creare costruire
abbattere i confini e fare qualcosa di
differente per la nostra terra
secondo voi la prima impressione conta
probabilmente sì probabilmente no mi
spiego che cosa abbiamo capito noi
abbiamo capito che a un certo punto
quando vedi una persona vedi un ambiente
vede una città anche quella dove siamo
adesso ti fermi a guardare un territorio
il territorio ha tante potenzialità però
probabilmente noi lo guardiamo solo per
quello che è a livello fisico
a livello di luogo
eppure noi
continuiamo ad essere isolati
continuiamo a fare in modo che questo
isolamento
diventi sempre più grande vorrei fare un
esercizio con voi immaginate non so se
conoscete maratea maratea un borgo una
città sul mare una piccola città sul
mare
sul terreno è sempre in basilicata è un
borgo arroccato che parte dal porto
arriva fin su a nelle montagne un posto
che nessuno potrebbe mai immaginare se
non per andare al mare andare in barca
fare l'aperitivo
al porto
però a un certo punto andiamo oltre
immaginate di vedere da sopra maratea
immaginate un albergo
immaginate di vedere in quell'albergo
tremila persone insieme
ecco cosa vedete in questa immagine
probabilmente ve lo dico io come la vedo
io vedo tante persone e buttate per
terra che fanno il saluto al sole o che
si stanno in un momento dire tre non sa
che cosa stanno facendo quelle persone e
una prima impressione possono sembrare
quello invece quelle persone vi dico io
che stavano facendo si stavano
preparando
ad un talk importantissimo di jeremy
rifkin sulla quarta rivoluzione
industriale e sono le stesse persone che
vediamo qui in attesa di ascoltare uno
tra gli esponenti più importanti
dell'economia perché vi dico questo
perché la prima impressione è un po
l'errore che noi facciamo nella vita ci
fermiamo a guardare le cose solo
nell'apparenza ci fermiamo a immaginare
qualcosa che non c'è ma che dovrebbe
esserci
ecco maratea maratea poteva essere
semplicemente un luogo per andare in
vacanza
e invece a un certo punto
tanti anni fa ci siamo ritrovati abbiamo
pensato perché non cambiare la visione
di un posto così
particolare così difficile impossibile
da raggiungere a a livello logistico a
livello infrastrutturale
perché non cambiamo tutto è la perla del
terreno è diventata subito capitale del
futuro in questo modo
[Musica]
paola tipo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ecco di certo non è un evento
convenzionale gli rossa non è un
festival non è il congresso che troviamo
a milano oa roma è una nuova concezione
di evento ma più che evento io parlerei
di ecosistema la possibilità di
ritrovarsi a heroes non esistono palchi
siamo tutti sullo stesso livello
ci possiamo ritrovare a parlare con bob
dorff a bordo piscina con uno spritz e
sentire lui che ti racconta come si
piscia come si fa un business plan
oppure ritrovarsi con farinetti con
bastianich a sentire come sta cambiando
il mondo
questo abbiamo provato a fare
tanti anni fa quando sono ritornato a
potenza
avevo proprio questo desiderio di fare
qualcosa di differente
ho ritrovato persone menti eccelse che
insieme a me l'hanno fatto perché il
team è fondamentale le persone che ti
seguono e che sono con te sono
fondamentali
quindi ritrovandoci io dico che essere
del sud e uno stato di visita e un modo
di vivere
quindi ci siamo ritrovati a noi ci piace
tanto a parlare e fare a fare a tavola
quindi pasteggiando mangiando bevendo
quelle cose che di solito succedono e dc
in una serata in cui mangi a sta creando
l'azienda del mondo oppure sta creando
il viaggio incredibile che la stima è
fatto quel giorno dopo ci dimentichiamo
tutto invece quella sera ci siamo
ritrovati e li abbiamo detto ma sai che
cosa vuol dire immaginati se prendi due
e tremila persone
le botti tutte insieme in un luogo
totalmente isolato un luogo che è un non
luogo luogo dove non esistono i computer
dove non esiste il fatto di voler
scappare da un'azienda all'altra da un
talk a uno speech andare via perché
intanto deve andare in ufficio per
ritorni mettiamoli insieme e così è nato
virus è nato ieri e
dagli eroi chi sono gli eroi allora
fondamentalmente non sono quelle a cui
ci hanno abituato
l'eroe non va in giro mascherato non
esce solo di notte non si nasconde
nessuno sa chi è
gli eroi siamo noi siamo le persone che
hanno deciso a un certo punto di
restare nel sud di investire nel sud
attenzione gli eroi sono anche quelli
che la mattina si sveglia e dicono ma
chi me l'ha fatta fare adesso basta
lascio tutto e me ne vado e quella sera
invece dicono ma che figata non aspetta
che lo rifacciamo di nuovo eroi sono le
persone che vanno insieme che sono il
gruppo e creano qualcosa una rete un
ecosistema un qualcosa che serve a
migliorare un territorio perché il
territorio ci può dare tanto ci può dare
gli spazi ma siamo noi a poter creare il
valore aggiuntivo del territorio vorrei
condividere con voi i tre ingredienti
fondamentali di heroes
il primo è già l'ho detto un po e il
team sono le persone un uomo solo è raro
che vada avanti
avere un team coeso persone che lavorano
insieme una comunità
uno spazio la possibilità di dare valore
a ogni persona che lavora con te è
fondamentale per creare qualcosa di
reale e per lasciare soprattutto
qualcosa al territorio
il secondo ingrediente la pazienza la
pazienza se non l'abbiamo e io non ce
l'ho però ho iniziato ad averla poi con
il tempo dopo un po di anni di heroes
perché purtroppo capita che gli eventi
il festival o qualsiasi attività che
facciamo in posti come questi comportano
tante difficoltà difficoltà logistiche
infrastrutturali la possibilità che ti
si ferma uno shuttle dall'aeroporto di
napoli e non ti arrivano più gli ospiti
un aereo cancellato persone che si
arrabbiano perché non c'è la connessione
è le possibilità e quindi vive nella
paura però la paura che alimenta la
paura ti aiuta assolutamente la paura ci
crea e ci dà la possibilità di fare
ancora di più il terzo ingrediente è un
telefono che funzioni sempre
internet laddove sia possibile e
linkedin linkedin è il passepartout
signore con linkedin si può arrivare in
qualsiasi posto poi arrivare a
contattare persone in ogni parte del
mondo e in un secondo portarle a
migliorare il tuo territorio a
raccontare alle persone che ci sono
quello che stai facendo quindi siamo noi
che possiamo creare poco a poco e
insieme una comunità insieme alle altre
persone un valore aggiunto
non ci fermiamo alle apparenze purtroppo
molto spesso ci ci soffermiamo a
guardare quello che c'è noi dovremo
andare oltre perché così come siamo qui
così come quando siamo a maratea un
luogo non è solo luogo non siamo isole o
continuiamo a credere che
resteremo in isolamento perché il mondo
è così grande e nessuno può arrivare non
è vero ne possiamo possiamo e dobbiamo
insieme fare tutto quindi ben venga a
richiamare la persona che incontrato
stasera di riesi ieri sera all'aperitivo
e dire che cosa facciamo insieme perché
l'ecosistema è fondamentale
l'ecosistema la rete è quello che serve
per un territorio perché il territorio
ha bisogno di noi oltre le apparenze e
qualsiasi cosa che facciamo fa bene non
solo a noi ma a tutta la comunità heroes
cerca casa se magari può essere che
l'anno prossimo saremo di nuovo qui
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]